Tyson Fury
his view, he says for
the best place for women,
is being on their backs or in the kitchen.
I'm glad he's not my client.
When it's spilled over, go on.
What's a bad moment?
I mean, the famous one was
Derek Chisora and Dillian Whyte,
where he picked up the table,
the press conference table and threw it.
It was aimed at Dillian Whyte,
but it actually went on myself.
Andy Murray, turned down one
and a half million pounds
to play in Saudi, because
of human rights concerns,
it does happen. I suppose,
there are individuals who take that,
Yeah, but it was a lot
more money than that,
and maybe if they offered Andy
Murray more he would've gone.
That was the boxing promoter, Eddie Hearn.
In this conversation,
you are going to hear
about why he didn't go to
court for Anthony Joshua
and why men still want to punch each other
in the face.
It's both the same and very different,
either way, promoters are
more powerful than ever.
and the stakes are just as high.
Hello and welcome, my guest this week
is promoter, entrepreneur,
and arguably one
of the most powerful people
in boxing, Eddie Hearn.
His company, Matchroom
Sport has been credited
with taking boxing to another level.
And his partnership with Anthony Joshua,
has got him into a few scrapes of his own.
Luckily just verbal, welcome Eddie.
Thank you.
Thanks for being here, and
I wanted to start by asking,
why do two people, do you think,
want to still punch each
other in the face, in 2022?
It is bizarre, isn't it?
And, there's kind of no excuse for boxing.
It's very difficult to explain to people,
and you know, the, the
argument will always come up.
If there is an injury in the sport,
specifically, which
has become a lot safer,
how does this exist, in
this, this modern day
world that we live in?
It's historic, there's so
many fundamentals to boxing,
which we'll probably
come to about actually
what the sport can teach
the younger generation.
But none of it really makes sense.
And it's the most compelling
sport, for me, in the world,
the most addictive sport.
Because, when you explain it to people,
it is two men and now women as well,
going into a 20 by 20
foot ring to have a fight
with each other in front of the world.
But what's going on between those two
people in your experience?
Because sometimes you will
have known both of them,
when you are promoting.
Do they actually want
to hurt the individual
or is it about what they're doing?
I think that, you know,
it's about winning.
It's a sport at the end of the day.
I don't think, sometimes people don't get
on with the opponent.
You know there's a,
there's a lot of things
I've heard,
Yeah, there's a lot of things
said backwards and forwards,
but generally, it's about, it's about
winning the fight tactically,
going in there and, and,
you know, executing a performance
that you've been working
on for weeks, months,
sometimes years, a fighter's
career reaches that moment.
But again, there are, these people,
they're not always normal people.
They can't be normal actually
to, to, do what they do
and to fight at that level.
So, you have to be a little
bit careful from my position.
You've gotta sell the
fight, hype the fight.
Sometimes it spills over.
I've been been in the middle
of that quite a few times.
But generally that sort of back and forth,
that animosity, that tension, and energy
between two fighters, is
ultimately what sells.
You know, it's what's gonna
create narrative and interest
to the public and to, to fight fans.
When it's spilled over, go on.
What's a bad moment?
I mean, the famous one
was Derek Chisora and Dillian Whyte,
where he picked up the table,
the press conference table, and threw it,
It was aimed at Dillian Whyte.
But it actually went on myself,
and Adam Smith, from Sky
and some great photos of that,
and stuff like that, but,
Were you scared?
Not really, I've been around boxing
since I was seven years old.
Yeah, but a table being thrown at you!
Had that happened before?
It was sort of, you know, blocked it,
but that way, that was a new one.
But you know, I've been
around because of, of,
you know, my dad being a promoter as well.
I've been around boxing
since I was eight years old.
I've been in the middle of
fights in, at press conferences.
fighters getting injured,
or crying backstage,
or cheering backstage,
or you know, every kind of emotion
that you see in a sport.
And it's incredibly
addictive because it is,
it's such a compelling sport.
And like I said earlier,
it's just, it's not normal.
Are you any good at fighting?
I had a couple of
amateur fights, terrible.
Are you tough now?
I'm not tough, I mean, I
was, I'm a silver spoon kid.
Aren't I, as my dad always called me,
but you know I, I grew up.
You know, my weekends were hanging around
with Naseem Hamed, or Chris
Eubank, or Frank Bruno.
So I thought I could
fight, but you, you don't
become really a fighter when you come
from my kind of background.
You don't think no.
No, very rarely will you find someone
who's come, come from a, you
know, a privileged background,
really, which I would
say I have, you know,
my dad's from Dagenham, and
you know, east London, but
he, he was successful and I,
I was very lucky, but it's
a different kind of life
you have to live as a
fighter and to come through
the ranks like these young men and women,
do you have to be made of tougher stuff.
And very rarely will you see
someone come from that kind of
background um, to go on
and make it in the sport.
And, and again, that's,
what's compelling as well
to be part of that journey.
My dad always said to me,
if you can get 1% of the
adrenaline that these fighters get,
when they walk out to fight,
you are a very lucky man.
And I feel like sometimes
I get 80% because you know,
the buzz is what we live for.
Also the money must be pretty good,
a billion dollar TV deal to
stream all of your fights.
How do you explain your
job apart from, you know,
being in the action?
What do you actually do?
Well, I, I guess I put it together.
I kind of like, when we started,
I started promoting boxing,
which was probably about
12 or 13 years ago.
I never went in with the
attention to kind of build my
profile to a level where I'm
part of the show as well.
And I should have, because
that was the right thing to do,
but it just emerged over
the years as we went.
But I'm like the, you know, the,
the guy who puts the
circus together, you know,
it's my job to go out,
to build the fights,
to create the narrative,
to sell the story,
to get the public and fight
fans invested in the event and
fights. And that's what
we do at Matchroom.
And we've gone, of course,
from, you know, being a, a,
a big UK promoter to being a
global powerhouse in boxing,
That streaming deal is with DAZN,
our TV partners and streaming
global streaming giant.
And that's taken us into
the U.S. with a big deal,
taking us into key
markets like Italy, Spain,
Australia, Mexico and, and,
We keep on expanding around the world.
And that's the plan for us is
to dominate boxing globally
with a different feel,
with a different kind of
professional touch to the live
event experience
both in the arena and for
viewers watching on the platform
So putting on that show,
getting it to people,
putting the business side
of it together. But as you,
you mentioned there about
taking a meeting, you know,
how does, for instance, Anthony Joshua,
how does that relationship start? Do you,
do you give him a card? How do you meet?
Yeah. Well with Anthony
Joshua, it's actually
quite a funny story.
I'll tell you quickly.
I received a letter once from
a gymnasium to say, look,
you know, there's this really
promising young heavyweight,
but he's got himself in some
trouble and he has to appear
in court, and we would like
you to come and talk about if this young
man was as good as we think
he is, what could he achieve?
Or what could the, you know,
the future hold for him.
And I looked at the letter and thought,
I don't even know the kid,
I'm not going to court.
It went straight in the bin.
And then I went up to the GB Institute.
And I just heard this noise.
And it was a heavy bag.
I know the noise well
just being moved around
you know, on its pivot
and I turned around to
Robert McCracken the coach and said,
who's that? And he said,
that's Anthony Joshua,
he's, this kid's special.
And I thought, oh, no, that
was the name on the letter.
I wish I would've responded. He went on,
went into the Olympics
and you almost hoped they,
don't win the Olympics because
then everybody's gonna be
after his signature. Of course
he won gold in London 2012.
In terms of British boxing,
probably world boxing as well,
we are probably the first stop
that you would go to for a
meeting, say, you know, when
you wanna meet other promoters,
you'd, you'd come to Matchroom.
So we had that meeting.
Sometimes I've got the
benefit of being younger
than the other promoters and probably
get on better with the younger fighters.
But, you know, with
Anthony, he was a, you know,
he was a dream signing because
he won gold at the London
2012 Olympics. He was a heavyweight.
He was articulate.
Did he forgive you for not going to court?
I told him the story. Yeah,
he was probably, I couldn't,
but I still couldn't believe
they asked me to do it.
But um, he was, he's
very intelligent Anthony,
and asked a lot of questions
and I could see him sort
of look at me as if to say,
I'm not sure I trust you guys.
You know? And I said to him
at the meeting, I said, look,
go and see everybody.
And then take your time,
make your decision.
Whereas everybody else said sign now.
And he went away for about
three or four months.
I never heard from him. I thought, oh,
I shouldn't have said that.
And then he came back
and he said, we wanna,
we wanna sign with you
guys, which was, you know,
a really big moment for our business.
It is still a largely male sport.
I know things are starting to change,
but do you think in some ways
- boxing represents in some
ways an outdated version
of masculinity or is it an
important part of being a man?
I think it's changing a
lot. You know, I think,
I think the world is changing
and sport is changing in that
respect as well. You know,
the openness across that,
that area, whether you're
talking about mental health,
you know, you see a lot
of fighters that struggle
in that area, as you do
with a lot of sportsman.
And I feel that people are, are,
are willing to talk more
about many different talking
points. Boxing has always
got the sort of, you know,
the perception of being
a tough guy's sport.
The influx of women's
boxing has been huge for us.
And we've been the real trailblazer with,
with the fighters to,
to take that part of the sport forward.
So I think it's changed a
lot over the years. I think,
you know, back in the day,
if you want to say that
that's that word, it was
definitely a sort of,
you know, brawn and,
It's still, it's still
like that though isn't it?
It is. But I think it's
changing. You know,
you've seen fashion brands
coming into the sport.
You're seeing a younger generation with
social media and content.
You're starting to understand
the characters more,
people are opening up more.
People are willing to talk
more people talk about their
trials, tribulations, you
know, their struggles.
They trash talk too.
Trash talk's great, for
us, because you know,
that's what, still, that's
what people wanna see.
Yes. Sometimes I'll do a really,
Yeah. They don't wanna see
somebody talking about their
mental health, do they?
No, but I think
They, they wanna see
them being pugilistic.
They wanna see all of that
Exactly, but I've got,
and I wonder, does that
perpetuate a stereotype of men
that you are saying
we're moving away from in other parts? I,
and there might not be
anything wrong with that.
I dunno if it is a stereotype,
it's how a lot of men still are and feel.
Yeah. But it's important
for us to tell stories.
I mean, we are also, you
know, we are event promoters,
but we're also content creators. You know,
we run our own production
company. We know we,
I like to produce content.
I like to tell the story of a
fighter, and their struggle,
and their life,
because that's how you create
personalities and gain fans.
And, you know, we need
fight fans to see that side,
not just someone walking in
and put, going head to head
with another guy and flexing his muscles.
Tell the story. Every
individual in boxing,
has a tremendous story, tremendous story.
You know, I've got Lawrence Okolie
the world cruiser weight champion.
He was working at McDonald's in Waterloo.
And one day he was flipping burgers.
He was grossly overweight and
he saw Anthony Joshua win gold
at London 2012.
And he walked out of
McDonald's. He says, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna take up boxing
and change my life.
He's world cruiser weight
champion. You know, there,
there are so many inspirational
stories in boxing.
But there are some of the
most famous, Tyson Fury.
And you look at what he
likes to say publicly.
Would you say that is defined
by role model, manners?
His view, he says for the
best place for women is being
on their backs or in the kitchen.
Mm. It's definitely not
something we support.
And he's quite a unique
individual with that respect.
But he's a big name.
Yeah he is a big name and not everybody
is everybody's role model
Of course not
but I suppose when you've
got those in the mix.
Yeah. but sure. But for Tyson Fury
away from those comments,
now this is also a guy that
came back from pretty much
obesity and, and, and
mental illness himself
to a lot of people, he
is a role model now,
Should he be?
that, that, that's based on
the individual's perception.
I think, it's not down to
me to say whether, you know,
I look after myself and my family
are they things that I
would want my children to,
to look up to, of course not.
I wouldn't even want 'em to see it,
but the fighters that I know,
Katie Taylor being the
best example in terms of my
daughters, alright.
There is no one that I would
like my kids to meet more and
be around than Katie Taylor.
So, is it very frustrating when there
are those characters
in your world? I mean,
he said he would celebrate
post March in 2020.
I'm not holding you to account
for what Tyson Fury says.
I'm glad he's not my client.
but he did say he'd celebrate
with cocaine and hookers.
You know, this, these
are the direct words.
I think it's important to
share with, with our viewers,
what I'm actually
talking about in the mix.
I also think that regardless
of the fact that, yes,
you're right. He is a big
name. It is in isolation.
You're always gonna get them.
You're always gonna get the
controversial characters.
Sometimes, I think actually
he says things that
he doesn't actually mean, but you know,
that's another story.
He says nice things about
you sometimes as well.
Sometimes, sometimes not often.
No.
no. And, but again,
He called you a bad businessman.
Yeah, well yeah.
Your last deal doesn't look so bad.
Exactly. The record speaks for
itself. Bit like his boxing
Do you, there we go, it's coming.
Do you get frustrated though, by that?
Does that bother you?
No, It's all part of the game.
And that's why when I
look at those comments,
although they shouldn't be said,
because he does have a position
as a role model in society
They, they go over my head
because I know the man,
you know, and,
But they don't go over some peoples heads.
No, I agree. But, but then, again,
this is the real life and we
can't expect perfection from
everybody, especially from
people that might not have
been brought up in that way.
And I don't mean that
disrespectfully for him,
but you know, these
aren't normal individuals.
Sometimes they say stupid things.
Sometimes they do stupid
things, we all do.
And sometimes people more so
than others. So, you know,
in that respect, you can
never condone those comments.
But, you know, again, I, I go
back to boxing, the community,
what it does for people.
And I know, you know, again,
going back to my kids,
there is no place I'd rather
them be than in a boxing gym
actually. And as for someone
who's got two daughters,
I, I never thought I'd say
that until I started to get
involved with women's boxing
and what Katie Taylor-
What Katie Taylor's taught me.
What, how she's inspired me.
You know, I don't go down
the gym and start boxing
because of Katie Taylor, but the values,
and the fundamentals
that she has in terms of
discipline and drive and winning.
Would you like your
daughters to be boxers?
If they wanted to be?
If they wanted to be.
You would support that?
I would. Now, when I talk
about them going into a gym,
I don't talk about them going
into a gym with a view to
become a professional fighter.
No, but it is interesting to
hear sometimes when people
work in an industry, if they
actually would put their
most precious person in there.
I want my, I want my children
to chase their dreams
in terms of the passion that's, that's,
that's lit within them, right,
and if that's through boxing,
then I would one hundred
percent support that. Now,
if I had a choice, would I
want them to be fighters?
Absolutely not. If I had a choice,
would I want them to be part
of our company, my company,
our family business,
Like you were with your?
Not really. No.
No, not like you took on from your father?
Not really. Because people
think that it's, you know,
a nice, you know, or it's
been given the reins,
if you like, but it's a
different kind of struggle.
You know, it's not the
struggle to necessarily
put food on the table, but it's a struggle
to make your own name in
your own right. Cuz when you,
when you're born to a successful
father and you see this in
sport, I mean, Chris Eubank,
you know, with his dad,
Connor Benn, one of our fighters
with his dad, Nigel Ben,
you're always Nigel Benn's
son or Chris Eubank's son. So,
the struggle is more to
create your own identity,
you know, and to do that, you have to
go above and beyond what they did.
Do you feel you've done it?
Yeah I do.
What was the moment you felt you did it?
I think with, with what
we've done for boxing,
you know, my dad was a
huge promoter in the UK,
you know, still is of course, snooker
but never went internationally
and did major TV deals,
never staged mega fights in America.
Like I have and all those kind of stuff.
And that was like a subconscious
chip on the shoulder to
say that's the only way
I can get respected.
Because otherwise I've just been given it.
And I was given it, you
know, I was given an
opportunity that others wouldn't have.
So, I had to go above and beyond that,
but I don't want my daughters
to have the same kind of
pressures if you like to sort
of try and outperform me,
but I want them to be
passionate about something.
And that's why I come back to
sport because we live in an
age where kids are on their
phones and that you know that
they're not out, they're not exercising,
they're reading negativity
on social media.
And it's just a complete,
you know, influx of,
of information in that
respect, sport is the answer.
On your deals and
forging into new markets,
getting that chip off your
shoulder and doing different,
doing different deals, bringing
boxing to different places.
You are forging into new
markets like the Middle East,
specifically Saudi Arabia.
And you said in 2019,
you wanted Saudi to be
the home of mega boxing
taking over from Vegas. How's that going?
Obviously there's been a global pandemic.
Yeah, well it was, you know,
we did Anthony Joshua against
Andy Ruiz, the rematch there,
which was went very well. You
know, it was a huge event,
obviously 2020 was
significantly slowed down, 2021,
sorry, from, from the pandemic,
there are talks with
not just Saudi Arabia,
but of course Abu Dhabi, Dubai, and,
and that region about
bringing major fights there.
And they're gonna be very
aggressive in that marketplace
because, you know, there is
a desire from those countries
to bring major sporting events there.
You talked though about
trying to do what's right.
And I wonder, do you have any
moral qualms about a country
where I don't know, women
weren't allowed to drive
until recently, human
rights concerns, especially
with Saudi Arabia?
Well, I think if they want to change
and if they're gonna change,
they need to make statements
and they need to bring a
focus on their territory.
I mean, you talk about, you
know, 'sportwashing', which is
a question that really
you're referring to.
Yeah.
And the answer is, is if
you want to modernize,
you know, a, a world or a
country like, like Saudi Arabia,
they want to do it in many different ways.
But bringing big events
to that territory is
very important to them.
When I say about, you know,
Formula One, going to Saudi
Arabia, the PGA golf tour,
WWE, major tennis tournaments.
It's not that I pass
the buck and say, look,
we're only boxing. What,
what, why shouldn't we?
But boxing is prize fighting.
Okay. So it's very different.
I don't really have a right to say to
Anthony Joshua and Andy
Ruiz, we've had this offer,
You guys are going in to fight each other.
And this is the opportunity for you.
I mean, Andy Murray, of
course, one of our, the UK's,
greatest tennis exports turned down
one and a half million
pounds to play in Saudi
because of human rights
concerns. It does happen.
I suppose, there are
individuals who take that.
Yeah, but it was a lot
more money than that, and
maybe if they offered Andy
Murray more he would have gone
But the opportunity only seems to be right
for your fighters if the money is right.
No. But that was my comment
on Andy Murray. I mean,
you're not talking about
No, no, no but you are saying to me,
they're prize fighters.
They're prize fighters.
So I'm trying to get
into the mentality of it.
But I'll give you an example.
Yeah, yeah
If a fighter was offered
five million dollars
to take a fight and there
was an opportunity to fight
for thirty-million dollars in a sport,
which is incredibly
dangerous, and you never know,
when it's your last opportunity
to be involved in a fight.
It's a different kind of conversation.
Rather than a million dollars
to play a tennis match.
If you Google you, do you do that?
Do you Google yourself?
Not,no
Come on you must a little bit?
No. Not for a long time, but
I think I probably have done.
Yeah, for sure.
Yeah, yeah, You did it last night.
Eddie Hearn and the memes.
Oh yeah
These memes of you. 'No context Hearn'
is a Twitter account that has
several hundred thousand
twitter followers.
What's your favorite one? These are,
these are things you seem to just do.
I just, yeah.
I mean, it's not you, is it?
Yeah.
Do you run that account?
Somebody thought you did.
Yeah, and it would've
been genius, you know?
And actually if I'd have thought of it,
I probably would've started it myself,
but it's a guy called Andy.
Oh, you know the person?
Yeah. He sent me the message on Twitter.
He works for the NHS and
he said to me, look, I,
I've watched your interviews.
Would you mind if I do this
'No Context Hearn'? No context
is something that exists,
you know, with some other sites as well.
Yeah.
And I was like, yeah, crack on mate.
I mean, how big can that
get? And it just went.
Two thousand followers, ten
thousand, twenty thousand,
a hundred thousand, two hundred
thousand, three hundred and
So he just takes clips of you?
Clips of my interviews. And then, and then
people use those clips in
context to something else.
So it'll say like, you
know, when Liverpool score
or win away at the weekend
and if you go, yeah.
So how, how do you feel about that though?
Cause some people wouldn't like it.
It's actually worked really well for me.
They wouldn't like themselves
being out of context.
I never take myself too seriously, Anyway.
I think that's very important in life,
but I actually, it's
worked well for me because
it's opened up a different
audience. You know,
I was known by fight fans,
but now you're talking about,
you know, kids sort of
young adults, you know,
more women cuz it's everywhere.
And, but the problem is,
is you get referred to as the meme guy.
And I took my kids to a
trampoline park the other day
and there was a girl
letting us in. So I mean,
she must have been, I don't
know, sixteen, fifteen.
And she went, is it you? And
I'm thinking, wow, you know,
Katie Taylor's obviously
working here. A lot of younger.
She goes, "you're the meme guy".
And I was like, and my
kids, you know that all,
when I picked them up from school,
all the kids are going-
they're not saying that
because I'm doing a show on Saturday,
they're doing that because
of 'no context Hearn'. So.
You're the funny man on the internet.
Yeah. But you know.
Have you got a favorite one of you?
Whatever it takes.
Is there one of you just
doing something you don't even
almost remember?
Yeah. There's, there's so
many. I mean there was me,
I was selling strawberries
on a, a market store in Hull,
because one of my boxers, their family,
has a fruit store in Hull.
A young lady walked past,
and I said, "you in the headband",
"you are different gravy" it's just,
they play it all the time,
and if there's a footballer
with a headband or I mean, it's just,
It gets re-used.
Yeah. And, but there's so many, so many,
I I've gotta ask you
cuz I thought about this
and I don't know quite my decision.
What would be your music
if you were a fighter and
you were walking in,
what would be the tune
that you would pick? You
must have imagined yourself
doing what some of your fighters?
You know, there's a song
by White Snake called
'Here I Go Again' or 'Here We Go Again'.
And it was actually a,
a song that Micky Ward,
a great Irish fighter
and American fighter used to walk out to.
And it's like, yes, yes, here we go again.
Walking down the only
road I know, it's quite,
it's quite deep.
And what would be your style do you think?
You walk out Eddie Hearn is
there, the man off the internet
I dunno. I mean just embarrassing.
Probably like I think I can
dance, I think I can sing.
Yeah.
I think I'm very limited
at both, but you know,
but I think that I would look the part.
You'd have to.
Yes. But I think once the bell went,
it'd be a major problem. Yeah. And it,
and it would be for me,
not for the other person.
Eddie Hearn, thank you so
much for talking to me and,
and to our viewers.
Thank you.
And thank you so much for being with us.
And until we meet again,
stay safe and goodbye.